after plan charter flight I think we all
feel a little ambivalent about it we are
you know what in this some of those
things too like what you know it's like
when you watch something that's
happening that you there's nothing you
can do about it like you know the people
who went back went back because they
were forced to go back and they are
among the people who've done the most
it's important to try to support us and
get her and I've worked really hard on
both like any way that they can and
basically all of the late night hosts
paid out of their own pocket we're out
of their companies pocket to support
their staffs after the network's stop
supporting our staffs and I think it's I
think it's very hard I mean it's hard to
honestly it's hard to watch the ship
forget the strike and everything else
it's a little bit like you know when
you're a kid and you miss a day of
school like if you missed Valentine's
day ever and sorry everyone's like
walking home with cupcakes yeah you're
and everyone else had a card and you're
like hope I didn't Kim now give me a
card because I wasn't there he's
otherwise if you were there came out
totally widows absolutely yeah it is
really hard it's like it is it's like
watching the next boyfriend walk around
with his new girlfriend yeah that has
never happened to me but because you've
killed every Xbox right there's no way I
could walk
that's has been really a good election
so far I mean we're taping this I'm not
sure when the spheres but no oh yeah no
lucky yeah Jamie Lynn Spears is pretty
good there's an election yeah I mean
there for president oh wow abune states
of america i'm actually i was listening
to BBC on the radio before I came over
here while reading newsweek yeah i like
to stay informed and and somebody was
like called in and said can we just hear
about the America some a British person
called in and said can we just hear
about this once the election is done do
we have to hear about the American
election with every primary that was a
funny thing to have a BBC person say but
um anyway it's yeah New Hampshire yes
it's exciting I mean it sucks we're
missing it because it's exciting to have
both primaries going like for both
parties and for both to be very tight
and for there to be so many candidates
right no such candidates Kenda two are
such a character yes yeah and all most
of them are very well known and defined
already right some of them are just like
so Mike Huckabee is hilarious yeah but
no surprises have you been totally
chomping at the bit cuz a part of me is
like not as Chompy as I thought it was
I'm a little bit Chompy you are choppy
yeah I really am I'm more Chinese
general a to be working music we get it
we get to work in a show so yeah she
gets like get our point of view out
there and like how fun is that and then
you know uh I mean I know that like
where I work we were really excited for
the South Carolina primary and I bet if
this thing won't be settled in the next
week maybe every day I go to sleep and I
think maybe I'll be settled tomorrow cuz
i really do think that there's like this
huge conspiracy there's all these back
channels working constantly and like
everything will get settled I can't tell
if it's that or nothing yeah yeah I just
usually be optimistic me thinks that
like everyone's like working like I'm
gonna get a call like get back here
you've got 10 minutes to get in but um I
don't think that's actually happening
but but this is such a great race and I
was like you know yeah Mike the micro
vault when they were talking one of the
dates where they're talking about the
environment and the guys like well if
you're so out of curiosity how many of
you took a private jet here and everyone
raised their hand except micro veil and
he's like I took the bus
I took the bus here from DC to get to a
presidential said it wasn't by choice
yeah it was like you have no idea how
little money I do carry a crated
chickens whether they might like you
might like Obama but not like you're not
gonna like her power as you're giving
him you have a power to listen where
he's got like a raid on it clearly you
think like Hillary Clinton would have
like laser tears that would kill it
you'd have laser tears that would like
like saw people and happen right so
laser tier Hillary yeah vs radar ear
Obama wow I message people listening
they wanna just could be sonar year I'm
just gonna say well what I'm not a
scientist okay I don't all probably we
should just to like cover our backs we
should give everyone a power to fly yes
look Omar's cuz she I'm so often flip
flops of the two people wow you are
really hey I'm and she's always she
takes the form of ice she's an ice queen
are you really for Hillary what do you
mean no I'm not but I mean I don't want
to just what if she ends up being the
eventual nominee from the party that you
seem to look and I would vote for her
grudgingly real politic with a k
well I think I mean Giuliani looks he
looks like a villain like he's got that
Skeletor risk of a villain yeah he's
pretty good and he eat she eats children
right yeah but I think in his defense
they're usually sibling